even the brightest stars can fall from
the sky and these Hollywood celebrities
go to show just how hard the impact can
be when they hit the ground and wind up
in
prison you might recognize Jen Shaw from
her television reality show The Real
Housewives of Salt Lake City but perhaps
these days that familiarity might come
from a different Source according to a
statement from the US attorney's office
Shaw was involved in a 9-year scheme
that used telemarketing tactics to
Target hundreds of unsuspecting people
including the elderly and sell them what
they called Business Services by lying
about the benefits July 11th 2022 Shaw
pled guilty to conspiracy to commit wire
fraud in connection with telemarketing
agreeing to Forfeit $6.5 million in
ill-gotten gains and pay up to $9.5
million in restitution as part of her
sentence she will serve 6 and2 years in
a Texas Federal Prison that sentence
seems lenient given that at one point
she was looking at a potential 30 years
in federal prison to make matters worse
for Shaw her famous lawyer priia shawrey
withdrew as Her counsel earlier this
year for breach of contract the defense
attorney alleges that Shaw failed to
make payment to her firm leaving over
$124,000 worth of legal fees
unpaid since 2014 millions of American
viewers have marveled at the financial
success of Todd Christley through the
reality television series Chrisley Knows
Best throughout this time audiences
assumed their wealth was amassed through
his business ventures as a powerful real
estate Tycoon but the reality is much
more complicated according to the US
attorney's office of the Northern
District of Georgia Todd and his wife
Julie spent a decade defrauding quote
Banks out of tens of millions of dollars
while evading payment to their federal
income taxes the couple secured over $36
million in personal loans by forging the
requisite financial information needed
by the bank then subsequently declared
bankruptcy once this money ran out their
outstanding debt was north of $20
million additionally they worked with
accountant Peter Tarantino to hide
$500,000 owed by Todd in accounts under
Julie's name they eventually took
further steps to keep their income a
secret from the Internal Revenue Service
town and Julie initially received
federal prison sentences of 12 and 7
years respectively however due to the
non violent nature of their offenses and
their conduct while in custody their
sentences were lowered by about 2 years
each under the first step act and are
subject to further reductions pending
evolving sentencing
guidelines in the late 1990s Tammy sit
known by her ring name Sunny became
arguably one of the most influential
wrestlers ever involved with the World
Wrestling Federation and long after the
company had rebranded as a WWE she was
even inducted into the WWE Hall of Fame
as the original Diva but in the Years
following a handful of WWE appearances
in the late 2000s re and criminal
Behavior landed her in trouble with the
law in 2015 sich was arrested for three
counts of drunk driving and was
sentenced to 90 days in prison after
pleading guilty to all three counts
tragically this began a pattern of
arrest for driving Under the Influence
that continued for several years until
her actions finally caused a tragedy on
March 25th 2022 sit crashed into a
stopped vehicle while driving at four
times illegal blood alcohol content
limit her blood also later revealed
traces of marijuana in her system though
sit survived the deadly Collision mostly
intact albeit with no apparent memory of
having even driven the car she killed a
75-year-old man in the other vehicle in
August 2023 she pleaded no contest to a
Litany of charges including manslaughter
and was eventually sentenced to more
than 17 years in prison after breaking
out in the 1990 John Waters film crybaby
Amy Lan landed a series regular gig on
the first season of the soap opera
Melrose Place she continued to play
supporting roles here and there for the
next decade or so until she announced
her retirement in 2006 following her
engagement to businessman Mark bovenizer
she continued to take part in local
community theater Productions after
closing a show with night of celebrating
drinking and driving between multiple
locations she crashed into a car stopped
at a red light when the driver of the
car exited his vehicle and approached
her to exchange information she
attempted to flee and a Chase ensued
ultimately locan driving 18 Mi above the
speed limit with a blood alcohol level
three times illegal driving limit
collided with another vehicle this time
killing a 60-year-old mother of two and
seriously injuring her husband let's be
clear what happened here this
woman decapitated my wife Lan was
convicted in 2012 of second deegree
vehicular homicide and assault by
automobile and was sentenced to 3 years
in prison 2 years below the minimum
sentence though the court Justified its
ruling by citing loc's record her child
being seriously ill and in need of care
and that the driver of the other vehicle
the deceased's husband had violated
RightWay rules the leniency of the
sentence caused an uproar despite being
released from custody in 2015 locan was
resentenced for four more times until
she was finally ordered to serve an
additional 8 years in 2019 she will be
eligible for parole in
2024 in early 2015 Josh Dugger was
arguably at the peak of his career 19
kids en counting the hit TLC reality
series had turned him in his
extraordinarily large family into
household names was a Network's most
popular program with an average of over
2.3 million viewers per episode the 27y
old Dugger was also the executive
director of a powerful Washington DC
conservative political action committee
called the family research Council it
helped him make good on the political
aspirations of his father Jim Bob Dugger
while lobbying against gay marriage and
abortion and rubbing shoulders with the
likes of future house Speaker Mike
Johnson Josh Dugger was arguably living
the Evangelical conservative American
dream then on May 21st 2015 in touch
weekly published a report outlining a
disturbing pattern of sexual abuse
perpetrated while he and his victims
were minors of the five victims two were
his siblings as a result TLC canceled
the series and Dugger resigned from his
position at F FRC with a public apology
in 2021 years after this apparently
contrite Retreat from public life us
Homeland Security discovered child
sexual abuse materials on dugger's work
computer investigators describe the
contents of his hard drive as among the
worst they've ever seen Dugger was found
guilty of receiving and possessing child
pornography on December 9th 2021 and was
sentenced to nearly 12 years in prison
he will not be eligible for release
until August
2032 K-pop fans are likely most familiar
with Chris Woo from his time with the
immensely popular South Korean boy band
EXO however many Americans might have
first encountered this Chinese Canadian
artist after he landed supporting roles
in the 2017 Vin Diesel Blockbuster Tri X
return of Xander cage and Luke besson's
valaran and the City of a thousand
planets in the years that followed his
Hollywood breakthrough it was alleged
that woo had been using his status as a
celebrity in China to manipulate and
assault multiple women one as young as
17 he was arrested by Beijing police in
2021 on suspicion of rape on November
25th 2022 woo was convicted of raping
three women and assembling a crowd to
engage in sexual promiscuity he was
sentenced to a total of 13 years for
both charges though an appeal attempt is
underway he's also been ordered to pay
600 million Yuan for tax evasion fines
controversy surrounded the trial with
some fans of woo rushing to his defense
by claiming he had been falsely accused
by one of the victims who they alleg was
extorting woo from money these
allegations have not been proven and
accounts defending woo were mostly shut
down Canadian diplomats have attempted
to gain access to Woo's appeals trial
but were ultimately denied entirely at
the the end of woo sentence he will be
deported from China throughout the 2000s
and early 2010s Jared Fogle quickly
became known for two things being one of
the most famous brand ambassadors in
America and one of the most famous sex
criminals in America after spending over
a decade helping Subway establish itself
as a healthy fast food brand allegations
surface that Fogle had used his position
to harass multiple women possessed child
sexual abuse material abused multiple
minors and even cross state lines to
commit sexual crimes against the minor
this is about using wealth status and
secrecy to illegally exploit children
though certain law enforcement
individuals had been aware of similar
allegations against Fogle since 2007 it
wasn't until the arrest of his associate
Russell Taylor the executive director of
the Jared Foundation fogle's charity
that authorities confirmed fogle's
involvement his home was raided by the
FBI on July 7th 2015 after which Fogle
was arrested for possessing and
distributing child sexual abuse material
a month later Fogo pleaded guilty to
both this charge and one count of
traveling to engage in elicit sexual
conduct with a minor as part of his plea
agreement Fogo was sentenced to 188
months in prison with the possibility of
parole after 13 years he was further
fined
$175,000 by the court forced to Forfeit
$50,000 in assets and ordered to pay a
restitution to each of his 14 victims
amounting to $1.4 million in total when
Fogle is released he will be placed on
the sex offender registry and will have
his devices monitored for the rest of
his life chances are you're not only
familiar with the bizarre case of
eccentric Oklahoma Animal Wrangler Joe
Exotic but we're one of the tens of
millions of people who watched it unfold
through several hours of the Netflix
series Tiger King released in March 2020
the series became an instant hit with
over 30 million people viewing it within
the first 10 days it appeared on the
platform as a result of an escalating
Larger than Life Feud with a
controversial CEO of Big Cat Rescue the
Western District of Oklahoma convicted
exotic of hiring two Hit Men to kill
Carol Baskin according to the United
States attorney's office he was also
found in violation of the Lacy act which
involved falsifying Wildlife records as
well as The Endangered Species Act
related to the killing of tigers at his
enclosure in the aftermath of the docu
series arean on Netflix exotic began
receiving support from a wide range of
Newfound fans including cardi B and
Donald Trump Jr though he was ultimately
unsuccessful in securing a presidential
pardon exotic did win a minor legal
victory in 2021 when a panel ruled that
he had been improperly sentenced in 2022
a federal judge resentenced him to 21
years in prison reducing his original
sentence by just one year year this
hasn't stopped exotic for making his
fourth presidential bid is second Behind
Bars the allegations against Danny
masteron had been surfacing for several
years before his conviction in 2023 in
2017 five women came forward with sexual
assault allegations against the actor
resulting in an immediate investigation
by the Los Angeles Police Department his
firing from the Netflix series The Ranch
and the end of his time as a client of
United talent agency on June 17th 2020
masteron was charged with three counts
of rape by 4 force or fear he baded not
guilty a year later and a trial
commenced in October 2022 I've heard
about you uh and you'll be caught soon I
know you will I will after a month of
Court proceedings in which the defense
chose not to call any Witnesses the jury
returned a mistrial verdict retrial was
held in May 2023 which ultimately found
Masterson guilty of two counts of felony
rape he was sentenced to 30 years to
life in prison and his first opportunity
for parole won't come until 2053 when
masteron will be 77 in 200 19 four of
his accusers filed a civil suit against
both masteron and the Church of
Scientology the powerful hollywood-based
religion that has long been the subject
of controversy and criticism the
accusers previously members of the
church themselves before allegedly being
excommunicated for reporting masteron to
authorities claimed that the church
tried to prevent them from going to the
police with their accusations in
addition current members were encouraged
to harass them in further retaliation
the results of the civil suit are still
pending of the handful of characters
professional kickboxer Joe son played
during his relatively short career in
Hollywood none made as much of an impact
as random task a riff on the iconic
James Bond Goldfinger villain OD job
from the 1997 film Austin Powers
international Man of Mystery this was
also the final role he played as his
life would quickly spiral into a cycle
of violence and criminality that
ultimately ended in a decades long
prison sentence son's first sent in
prison came after he pleaded guilty to
felony vandalism for kicking in his
roommate's door he received an initial
sentence of 60 days of jail time after
which he was sentenced to 90 more days
for violating the terms of Cooperative
surveillance established in his plea
deal while in custody for this probation
violation Sun's DNA was connected to a
heinous sexual assault that took place
in 1990 he was subsequently charged with
numerous counts of a range of sex crimes
but before the trial began these charges
were dismissed due to statute of
limitations rules the only charges
prosecutors were able to try son on were
conspiracy to commit murder and torture
as they were crimes that did not expire
under the California Penal Code he was
found guilty in 2011 and was sentenced
to 7 years to life in prison a month
into serving his prison sentence son
murdered his cellmate and in 2017 he was
convicted of voluntary manslaughter and
sentenced to an additional 27 years in
prison though not a star in the
traditional sense it could be argued
that Harvey Weinstein's very public
arrest and subsequent conviction is one
of the most impactful legal events in
the history of the entertainment
industry following an investigative
report from The New York Times at
alleged three decades of sexual
harassment assault and rape perpetrated
by the powerful film producer over 100
women came out as victims of his
innumerable crimes even more women came
forward with similar stories working in
Hollywood kickstarting a rapid
industrywide Reckoning with sexual
assault as a conversation on workplace
sexual harassment and misconduct
expanded Weinstein was investigated by
officials from Los Angeles New York City
and London England in 2018 he
surrendered to the NYPD on several sex
crimes charges filed by two accusers 2
years later he was found guilty of third
degree rape and first-degree criminal
sexual activity at the age of 67 and he
was sentenced to 23 years in prison in
the subsequent Los Angeles trial
Weinstein was once again found guilty of
numerous sex crimes including sexual
assault and rape and was sentenced to an
additional 16 years in prison in 2022 it
was announced that London authorities
would charge Weinstein with indecent
assault of which the case is still
pending along with these criminal cases
Weinstein has also been civil sued by
several individuals including former
victims and actors who alleged their
careers were derailed by refusing his
advances on May 19th 2014 Michael J shot
and killed his wife in front of their
two young children it was caused by a
domestic dispute that prosecutors
alleged stem from her desire to file for
divorce and his paranoia that she was
cheating on him the then 53-year-old
actor apparently next called his wife's
father to ask him to retrieve the
children before calling 911 to confess
his crime police took him into custody
that evening Jace had previously been
featured in several well-known films and
television shows in 2002 he was cast as
officer Julian low on the popular FX
police procedural series The Shield a
role which he played for for over 6
years before the show ended in 2008
though it was some time later that Jace
would be brought before a court for his
violent acts those who knew him closest
alleged during his murder trial that the
pattern had always been there in sorn
statements numerous individuals claimed
he was abusive to both women he was
married to in 2016 he was found guilty
of second deegree murder and was
sentenced to the maximum of 40 years
with the possibility of life
imprisonment we the jury and the above
entitled action find the defendant
Michael Andrew Jace guilty of the crime
of murder of April J he will be eligible
for parole in
2056 in Riverdale season 4 episode 1
Chapter 58 in Memorial Canadian actor
Ryan Grantham guest start as Jeffrey
Austine in his soul series appearance
airing in 2019 this would be grantham's
final role before he enacted a broad yet
deadly scheme that ended in the killing
of his mother Grantham had reportedly
experienced a rapid mental decline in
the months leading up to the March 2020
crime that manifested itself in drug
abuse a consumption of disturbing
material and suicidal ideation for a yet
unknown reason he chose to execute his
mother before embarking on a drive to
Ottawa it was there armed with guns
ammunition and makeshift explosives he
planned to attack his high school and
afterward assassinate prime minister
Justin Trudeau on route to his school
however Grantham experienced what the
judge interpreted as a moment of
Lucidity or moral Clarity and instead
drove to the nearest police department
where he turned himself in Grantham
pleaded guilty to second-degree murder a
crime which carries an automatic life
sentence in Vancouver at a sentencing
hearing the judge ruled that Grantham
would be eligible for parole in 14 years
at which time he will be in his mid-30s
mitigating circumstances that
contributed to the leniency of a
sentence were his behavior in prison his
participation in psychiatric programs
while in custody and his perceived
remorse in the eyes of the Court
starting in 2011 the Discovery Channel
began producing a reality television
series called Sons of Guns which
followed the day-to-day operations of
Louisiana based firearms company Red
Jacket Firearms LLC the company was
owned and operated by William Hayden a
bat Rouge native who had been fascinated
with Weaponry his entire life in August
2014 Hayden was arrested on charges of
juvenile molestation and aggravated
crimes against nature a relatively broad
legal term that includes any sexual acts
the state deems to be unnatural despite
Hayden denying these claims the
Discovery Channel quickly canceled Sons
of Guns and Hayden was legally separated
from Red Jacket Firearms LLC soon after
increasingly disturbing allegations
arose and after multiple separate legal
proceedings Hayden received three
consecutive life sentences plus 40 years
for a Litany of sex crimes if you or
anyone you know has been a victim of
sexual assault help is available visit
the rape abuse and incest National
Network website or contact Reigns
National helpline at 1 1800 656 hope
[Music]